These are tax brackets for 2019,...
Simple, right?
...but many of us make a common mistake when looking at this.
Let's say my income is 84,000 dollars.
You might think that puts me in the third bracket,...
...so I would owe the federal government 22% of my income.
This is wrong,...
...and it's causing us to have uninformed debates about tax policy.
Here's how it actually works.
Let's go back to my 84,000-dollar income.
Now, instead of thinking of tax rates as brackets,...
...we should think of them as pockets,...
...but first, there's one special pocket we need to talk about.
The money we put in this pocket is not taxed.
The government automatically lets single people...
...put 12,000 dollars in this special pocket and more for couples,...
...but if you spend a lot of money on things...
...like medical expenses or charitable donations,...
...you can sometimes put in more.
These are called deductions.
With the 70,000 dollars that's left over,...
...we can start filling up the pockets.
The first pocket only has room for 9,700 dollars, so I only pay 10% on this money.
Then I pay 12% on the money in the next pocket...
...and then 22% on the money in this pocket.
These are called marginal tax rates.
...and that's how these brackets actually work.